anh ạ
anh alo chào các bạn ạ
à à
anh alo
ờ ờ
khi
cha bây giờ trước khi vào buổi học thì
mình tranh thủ cho các bạn
Em ở trọ các bạn xem mà
ở một vài cái mà hôm trước mình có lưu
ca nhạc à bây giờ cũng chưa đến giờ học
mà nó ngon cho bạn xem video này cũng
hay này
em không biết là các bạn xem chưa mình
thấy hay phết
à mình mình mở tiếng không biết các bạn
nghe đúng lại thử xem
và
gia đình luôn luôn là biểu tượng vẫn sắc
của tôi đấy
ờ ờ
mic mình đang không Tạm thực không mở to
được vì nhà mình hơi ôn em mình hơi ồn
và
gia đình luôn luôn là biểu tượng vẫn
khắc của tôi nếu không có gia đình chưa
chắc ngày hôm nay tôi đã đứng trên đỉnh
vinh quang này gia đình luôn phản đối
tôi làm việc kiếm tiền họ không tin
tưởng thôi Được đó cho nên tôi loại là
khỏi bàn cân luôn người trẻ không nghĩ
có tiền ở xưởng khác không có tiền nhiều
chưa chắc đã sướng Bởi vì tiền không thể
nào mua lại
tiền là hạnh phúc nhưng đứa nào là khác
đấy đánh được tiền
một người lít giờ giỏi luôn luôn về
hướng dẫn cấp dưới của mình đứng cùng
mình đứng nha hàng của mình cùng một con
thuyền cùng một chiến tuyến đến thành
công không bao giờ tuyển nhân viên mình
những hình ngân hàng với nó rất là sếp
những cái là nhân viên có lúa không phải
bằng nhau được thế mà có thằng nào cũng
nó là sếp của mình thì thả xuống làm chủ
chính mình
Anh chúc em một kiếm được tiền các bạn
phải mình mất tiền rất nhiều lần
1 Khi bạn mất đi lên là bạn kiếm được
tiền đâu không được để mất tiền
đợi thì hình như là đang bị lag đúng
không Lại mất kết nối như vậy không
vì mình đã không thấy gì cả
Em có phải là bị mất kết nối
đầu
[âm nhạc]
tiên của mình để đưa tác phẩm ở độ tuổi
này thì 20 30 tuổi các bạn đừng chỉ chăm
chăm kiếm tiền bạn phải đâu chú ý thức
của mình khi các bạn hãy giúp các bạn đã
kiếm tiền rất người Chăm là người khác
nếu mà không học được đấy thì bỏ học đi
kiếm tiền từ sống tôi này thì bây giờ
bạn có gấp 5 gấp 10 lần số tiền thì mình
- chỉ chăm chăm kiếm tiền các bạn có
đang Mây bởi vì đam mê sẽ giúp các bạn
tìm kiếm tiền một khi mà đã kiếm tiền
bằng đam mê thì không còn 5 nói thật
luôn trước khi một kiếm được nhiều tiền
các bạn phải biết thì ngủ cái gì được
phải kiếm tiền trước rồi nó xác định
mình muốn gì bởi vì là mình muốn mời
Không có tiền thì là được
Có công rất thương để làm giàu đó là bấm
trên vai người khổng lồ Nếu đứng trên
vai người khổng lồ thì bạn sẽ có thể có
được làm nhìn vợ chồng rồi luôn luôn học
cách làm giàu từ những người giàu như
nước Đừng bao giờ nghe lời chúc cùng dầu
nó sẽ không bao giờ giúp bạn kiếm tiền
đâu khi bạn giàu ấy
khi bạn làm tốt cá bạn làm chủ được nữa
vì bạn nghĩ đã rất ngầu như khi con voi
đế và nó thuốc hồ nước đó thì con voi
với lại chủ mua được nhà cái nguồn nước
lại thấy thằng Đức quá quên em anh cho
ít tiền cho nhau nước này chúng ta thì
anh nói có đúng không anh nói đi Ừ thế
em ạ anh
không đi đâu à
[âm nhạc]
chứ
không phải tự nhiên mình chia sẻ video
này cho mọi người xem ra mình vừa thấy
bây giờ khác hay mà kiểu Nó là kiểu dáng
và kiểu
anh nói chung về cách dạy đời mà bây giờ
thường mình thường ấy thấy rất nhiều
áo kiểu lên mạng đầy Trang đang ngồi
triết lý có tử Thậm chí mình đang nói
chuyện tự chia lý Thực ra thì
ở trong video nói nó ra Kiểu
Ừ nó là trẻ tổng hợp lại những cái câu
mà người giàu hay chia sẻ nếu như các
bạn xem chắc tay thế
Một sắc Nói kiểu này xong rồi Sắp kia
phản lại luôn ấy thì theo như mình thì ạ
Các bạn không nên sự là kiểu nghe lời
tuyệt đối một like cả cái học hỏi vẫn
đang học không Chúng ta không nên và thu
không nên kiểu mình là nhất mình không
cần phải nghe ai cả Thế say quá Nhưng mà
mình cũng kéo
ở
nhà mình cũng kiểu dạng là
Ừ mình không cần phải nghe đó mới cái
cực đối như thế mà học cái gì đó kệ thôi
không ạ
có cách cách mì trường đại học đó là
mình sẽ thấy ai có gì đó hay
thì mình sẽ tìm hiểu cách họ giải quyết
vấn đề khi mà gặp vấn đề đó như thế nào
em sợ ít người ít người giàu chia sẻ
được đấy
có người giàu toàn kiểu chia sẻ
ở chỗ cách để họ thành công ấy nhưng mà
không nghe được chia sẻ cách mà khi họ
gặp khó khăn
Ê trái giật mình mình cần trả lời cái
câu mà khi họ gặp khó khăn họ sẽ giải
quyết như nào hơn bởi vì là cách để mà
họ thành công ấy Bây giờ mình áp dụng y
nguyên những cách của hỏi chị làm sao mà
được cái họ nữa đúng không Thế nên là
chúng ta không nên bắt chước nhé tương
tự như thế với hợp thực hình ảnh thế
Mình chỉ các bạn mới trẻ con đường dễ
dàng nhưng mà thật sự thì đôi khi là các
bạn ôm cốt đấy về chạy thì có bạn trai
được như là các bạn gặp thêm những cái
lỗi lặt vặt khác những vấn đề khác chỉ
ra các bạn không khó mà giải quyết được
anh đúng không Thì
thì
mình sẽ dạy các bạn chủ yếu là về tư duy
và cách xử lý tình huống hơn là kiến
thức bởi kiến thức không đủ và kiến thức
đấy có thể là cách dạy đấy Có thể phù
hợp với mình với cách học đấy phù hợp
với mình nhưng mà chưa sắc phù hợp với
các bạn đúng không thì các bạn không cần
phải ốp nguyên để mà để em muốn được như
anh cần phải đi theo con đường của anh
không chả cần phải làm thế đúng không
các bạn chỉ cần học hỏi ví dụ là khi
mình gặp vấn đề mình giải quyết như thế
nào
Ừ
mình bao giờ chán cốt chưa
ờ ờ
gần đây là mình
nhà mình có mình chưa biết là mình chia
sẻ các bạn chưa mình có cái công cụ qua
Qatar này để đo xem một tuần mình cốt
bao nhiêu tiếng
thì các bạn sẽ thấy da á Cái cả cuối
tuần Mỹ đuổi là
à mình làm có tháng là có tuần cao nhất
Mình làm hơn tám mấy tiếng gần đây mình
mới giúp lại 70 tiếng Việt à
Mà công nhận cũng cao sốt lại Ừ nhưng mà
các bạn sẽ thấy là
Ừ ừ công ty không không yêu cầu mình làm
về nhá công ty chỉ yêu cầu mình làm 8
tiếng 5 ngày trong tuần thôi
Ừ nhưng mà mang nhiều kiểu Nó thành thói
quen rồi Và
ạ bây giờ nhỉ dịch hay là kẹo cứ dạy on
Ngồi ngồi cốt các bạn sẽ thấy 80 tiếng
mà có 70 tiếng một tuần mới làm việc
chắc anh giàu lắm
sữa
mình còn không
mình còn không báo với bởi Với quản lý
nhân sự
đã có nhiều người biết mình tiền hình
yêu mình nghe cái xong kiểu cay làm hô
hô mình không để báo làm thêm giờ từ thứ
với ạ ạ
có phải quản lý nhân sự để mà trầm không
hả mình bởi vì thực sự thì mình làm nó
cũng na ná giống kiểu đam mê hơn vào kia
áo kiểu cũng hay mày ở đâu là cái ngày
này kiếm được các thứ thứ không có bạn
bảo là kiểu thế chết nó chết đói
nên cái này nó thành thả que rồi và mình
không coi đó làm việc thành ra 50 triệu
mình mới thấy thoải mái như thế nhưng mà
không tính toán để cái việc và hôm nay
mình làm hôm sau mình chơi Dự chỉ nhớ
lúc và kẹo Mình thèm chơi quá mình chơi
thôi chứ mình làm Mình cảm thấy
à
không phải nói là sẽ rất là thư giãn
được Làm lập trình gì không có chuyện
thư giãn
là sự trình và chuyện thư giãn nhìn não
mình chắc là không hoạt động với thời
gian và thư giãn Nếu mà kiểu mình cảm
giác sướng khi mà giải quyết được một
vấn đề gì đó cả nói kích thích nó là cái
nghiện giống như bạn trên nói nó ra thí
nghiệm ạ
Áo kiểu kiểu dạng khi mà bạn giải quyết
được một vấn đề gì đó với các bạn yêu
thích thì thôi
vì nó không nó khác với kiểu các bạn hồi
làm toán nhé
thì các bạn không phải ngồi giải toán
các bạn dễ cảm thấy nó viển vông Vớ vẩn
cái nào thực tế cái này ra là kiểu nó bị
thế
có thể bạn bảo bạn đam mê nhưng mà cái
tủ Đam mê nó thực sự rất khó thì xác
định cái định nghĩa về đam mê Nói chung
là kiểu nó cứ đại khái như kiểu mình
từng nói sinh viên
ý là khi mà em
cho em hỏi đam mê Cái này thì ra em
không cần phải nói năm nay cái gì đâu mà
em phải hành động sao cho mà bây giờ
ráng hỏi thằng bạn thân của em hay Họ
Bất kỳ ai cậu chỉ cần chơi em còn thời
gian thôi họ có thể nói được em đam mê
Cái gì thì chứng tỏ là
Ý là em đúng là đồ nghề đấy hết anh
giống như kiểu hỏi bố mẹ em chẳng bố mẹ
em hỏi họ nhiều bố mẹ nhiều không người
ta phạt hai Suốt ngày cắm mặt vào điện
tử máy cưa thế Chứng tỏ ông Nam điện tử
sẽ đơn giản thế thôi mà đúng không ạ
có kinh nghiệm yêu giá mình có bao nhiêu
Sau đó mình nhé Mình lôi kéo được bạn để
về đây mà
anh cũng ai May là bởi vì mình cho sự
nghiệp cũng tương đối hòm sau ngoài Kiều
cũng có gọi nhà con gái chưa có sự xài
con gái thích một người có chính kiến tí
nên tham gia là mình
sử dụng cái chứng kiến kết hợp và kỹ
năng gì à
có kỹ năng thuyết phục của đa cấp lô
chéo được bạn đấy từ trong Sài Gòn ra
đây
khuyên Mấy ông không phải ông ạ chơi thế
được nhưng mà
anh khuyên mấy ông Hà kiểu
có
phải thể hiện mình gì gì đó một khi mình
làm cái đấy mà đam mêm không Mình quyết
liệt đó
30 30 game xong rồi để làm game thủ cái
này nhiều những thứ mà không Ví dụ của
Giả sử mình mình cũng là một kênh mà
sách các thứ nhưng mà các bạn đang có
suy nghĩ giống như cái video rồi là các
bạn đang suy nghĩ này của đam mê Kiếm
tiền từ nó cái này không hạt đam mê này
nói cho một mình làm ngày đêm vì nó được
Nhưng mà chọn nó thành phương pháp kiểm
kiếm tiền ấy thì tùy
ô nhiễm mà kiếm được thì tốt đúng không
Còn không thì em mình
mình mà cứ ép nó thành cái công cụ kiếm
tiền đôi khi mình sẽ mất hẳn đam mê thật
khi mình bị người yêu rỗi mời cốt quá
nhiều ạ Cái chạm tỉnh có tâm sự dân công
nghệ mà đúng không chia sẻ thì à
em đến như là rất sáng là người yêu khó
chịu có thứ rất nhiều cái rồi
ừ ừ
không giống nhiều kẹo có ông này cho
biết tôi ở tôi còn làm admin của Trang
gái xinh nữa thằng ạ Đây Thực ra là
trong điện thoại của tôi đang lưu phải
mấy chục nghìn mấy chục nghìn ảnh gái
xinh mà không không nói người yêu luôn
có chi mà lướt Facebook của tôi gần như
mọi người đã từng thấy chỉ có soi gái
thôi mọi thứ đều gái các thư
ạ bây giờ cũng là theo dõi người yêu
nhau mà
ở gần như trong cơ thể và người yêu gì
hết thế các từ kia thì
Ừ cái đấy và đương nhiên à Nó là con con
người của mình sẽ nhờ tôi không khuyên
mấy ông đến thế
à mà đã nói là thể hiện mình là mình là
thế mà không ảnh hưởng không để nó ảnh
hưởng đến chuyện khác cứ giả sử nó kiểu
Ừ ông hay làm đái rồi ông không nhắn tin
gái đâu phân nghĩ xong rồi ông tán tỉnh
cái Vân thế không được đúng không còn
ông chỉ khán giả trong nước trong năm và
để em ra mục đích của tôi theo dõi nhiều
người như thế cũng là chị chia sẻ tính
Tôi rất thích chia sẻ
tôi chia sẻ cho anh em để anh em xem
cùng Nói chung ai nó cái đẹp nhưng tôi
Thưa ngài chia sẻ
Cô Đơn giản thế thôi Chứ tôi không phải
kiểu cuồng nó quá
a cho thể hiện được việc gì ra việc đấy
thì mọi thứ nó thoải mái với những kiểu
chơi game mình chơi game mình Mình công
nhận dành thời gian cho người yêu mình
sẽ đôi khi rất ít ra mình cũng thấy có
lỗi gì đấy
Ừ mình cũng có nói bạn ấy thường xuyên
nói bạn đấy cái điều em chứ cái rồi Để
mình bây giờ nhé Tôi đang dành thời gian
cho mấy ông đấy mà gỡ ràng là tôi vừa
phải ăn cơm vội đến mà cậu đứng dậy dậy
vào vào lớp học luôn chứ làm gì có thời
gian cho bạn đấy mấy đâu
anh nói Trung Hà cái này thực ra mình
còn đôi khi nghĩ rằng cái việc bà
à
mình mình đôi khi nghĩ việc làm nó giống
như lợ em có có nhiều người tập trung
vào công việc Quái tập trung vào mọi thứ
quá không dành thời gian được cho mối
quan hệ của mình nhưng mà mình vẫn phải
biết thu xếp cân đối thôi Không
tôi không khuyên với ông như tôi bây giờ
tôi vào tôi chẳng tốt đẹp gì cả à
Ồ không Tôi không ngờ nó mấy câu kiểu
ngôn tình kiếm tiền thật tôi tựa Có xin
xuống như tôi sẽ không được dùng mày
cong ngôn tình kia cả cả
em anh ngắm tí em nhưng mà thật ra chỉ
yêu mình em không tôi không vừa nói cô
ấy luôn
chung cư hành động mà làm
khi Trình bày kiểu nói câu đấy với bạn
đấy khi nghe hiểu mày hay nhưng mà Nó
kiểu nó cứ ăn của passport
Thành ra là không
khi con người yêu bằng gái đúng
Ừ nhưng mà tôi không nhận lỗi tôi thiên
thần tôi xin chúa bạn đấy thôi nên tôi
không biết lãng mạn lắm Bởi vì cái lãng
mạn tôi cứ cảm thấy nó cứ giả tạo cái gì
mình có thể tự nhiên nữa thử cái ai nhá
Tôi từng đọc cái này nó không liên quan
lắm nhưng mà đây thì nếu không biết bí
quyết để mà yêu lâu nó gì không
ừ ừ
vụ bí quyết yêu lâu ấy nhận xét là họ
quen để sự nhàm chán của nhau rồi
anh alo nói bé Alo hôm nay mức Đúng rồi
mẹ ạ
ờ
ờ Họ quen được sự nhàm chán của nhau
Vì thế nên là họ kiểu sống rất là bình
thường mình nhau tự nhiên là cũng sẽ cậu
có lúc vui chơi giải trí có tới giờ
nhưng họ quen mình mọi mọi cuộc sống
hàng ngày với nhau chứ không phải là
à à kiểu dạng là ngày nào cũng phải lắm
ạ Ngày nào cũng phải hiểu gì đó ghê gớm
Âm Nhạc
à à
ừ ừ
ê ê
cô bạn kia đang nói về cái vụ liên quan
đến tình yêu và hóc môn kích thích chồng
khó
Ừ ừ
quan điểm của mình về cái vụ
yêu giống như bạn vừa nói gà chỉ nó lại
hơi khác một tí bạn đang bảo là hoóc môn
kích thích nhưng mà Đấy không phải là
yêu còn giai đoạn yêu diễn ra sau đó thì
ra là khi nó lại hơi sai
quan điểm của mình nha mình tin có tình
yêu sét đánh thật mình tin nào đó kiểu
dáng không hẳn là cái duyên nhưng mà nó
kiểu khi mình nhìn thấy một người thì
mình có tình cảm người ta
quyết định quyết định ở có tình cảm với
là không nhanh cực
quyết định yêu không nhanh còn Khi mà
mình quen người ta lâu rồi mà bắt đầu
nảy sinh tình cảm nữa đấy không phải đi
đâu Nó là kéo nó là lý trí can thiệp vào
rồi mình có suy nghĩ nhiều người ta mình
kiểu
quen làm giác đấy có thứ thành thói quen
ý ý Ừ thế hơn
Ừ thôi vào lớp mình ở
nhà mình đang hơi bị ồn Các bạn thấy bị
ồn quá đi mình sẽ chỉnh nhỏ lại make có
gì có bào mình nhé bởi vì nhà mình đang
mình đang thuê nhà thức nó có rất nhiều
vấn đề đấy thì kiểu phải đi sửa Con thử
liên tục đi ừ
ở đây thì trước khi vợ à mình xin phép
chia sẻ những cái này sau đi hôm trước
thì không hiểu gì không có câu hỏi nào
cả họ hôm đấy trả lời hết rồi
Ừ anh thấy ra là mình xin phép và
mình dậy sau đó đi mình đã Mới chia sẻ
về những cái thứ này à
à à
thì các bạn có thời ý buồn quá không có
nghe được tiếng bên ngoài không
[âm nhạc]
anh alo Bây giờ ngoài kia đang cãi nhau
các bạn nghe tiếng ở bên ngoài à
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ
ạ
Bây giờ có đang nghe được tiếng mẹ mình
đang cãi nhau
cha mẹ mày gì
đấy là mẹ mình ấy mẹ mình là người
anh chửi nghe hát
Vì thế nên là mình cũng được kế thừa cái
việc nó nhiều từ mẹ
ừ ừ
anh không Mẹ tôi đang chửi mấy cái ông
thợ cả thơ thứ ạ bởi vì a
gọi sửa xong rồi vẫn còn đây mà hát à
ừ ừ
Ờ Ờ Đấy ra mà mình nên mua cái mic anh
em mua cái tai nghe
mình đang bị ảnh hưởng bên ngoài khá
nhiều Buôn nói
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là hôm nay là mình sẽ học về
thẻ Liên kết này
số thẻ liên kết
thẻ Liên kết nó là kiểu khi mình bấm vào
cái bấm các bạn đây để mình chỉ các bạn
về những cái thẻ và nhận
thiết kế hệ khi mà các bạn thấy là đây
là một trang web dantri.com để bạn ạ
ạ sau đó thì bấm vào cái đường link này
thì các bạn thấy nó sẽ chuyển sang một
cái file đó là file chấm HTML HTML nhá
chứ không phải ạ Cái chấm HTM ở trong có
viết tắt của HTML Thôi thì thì nghĩa là
khi bấm vào cái này bạn chất nó sẽ nhảy
sang cái file chậm HTML khác đều ngoại
đi
ờ ờ thì
Ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy cư cơ bẩm như thế
này thì nó sẽ nhảy sang wifi trên mất ml
Nào Đó Đúng mà thậm chí là các bạn còn
bấm vào được Xem ảnh to lên để làm cái
gì đó như thế này không cái này bấm nhầm
tỏi nó khác đó Mình nhớ có một vài cái
bấm cho
dỗ kiểu kiểu như thế này
Ừ đấy thì nó mở hàng kẹp khỏi cái ảnh
nào đó khác đấy thì nó là thẻ Liên kết
là thứ mà hôm nay mình sẽ học điều hòa
à à
như vậy tỉ lệ tính đến mình nha Tắt hết
mấy cái mở buổi hôm trước nhé
ở đây thì mình vẫn có cái file để mô hôm
trước này nhưng bây giờ mình sẽ thay nó
bằng
Ừ
cái cái để mà nhảy sang được một file
khác là sử ở đây có cái file à đền mua
hai chẳng hạn thì sẽ có là Hello chị ạ
Đây thì từ file này nhảy sang file này
mình muốn nó từ file để mô chấm HTML
sang demo 2 thì mình sẽ có thể a a như
này
em có thể anh á
Thế a này sau đó thì mình sẽ dụ là mình
phải có mỗi nội dung của bên trong đã
sửa đây là link virus cho này
các bạn sẽ thấy à Nếu mà Thì ai của Mình
chưa điền một cái gì cả
Vì Mình chưa điền vào cái gì cả thì nó
sẽ
trông giống như ở một cái bình thường
mình chẳng Click vào được mà nói rằng
hiển thị giống như một cái đường link mà
các bạn thường hay gặp Giả sử mình thêm
hẳn Hz bản demo 2 chấm hát em ở đầu khi
bạn sẽ thấy à bây giờ nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu
hiển thị ra theo dạng là cậu đường link
các bạn trỏ chuột vào thì thấy có vẻ là
bấm được và các bạn bấm vào thì nó sẽ ra
đúng không nó sẽ ra được cái file ở bên
này đúng ngoan thì đấy là thẻ thẻ tiêu
đề À nhầm thẻ Liên kết thì
chú ý mình đang định nói là cả vụ tiêu
đề nữa thì biết là bạn muốn hiển thị ra
cái này Nội dung nhé Được cái này nội
dung thôi còn các bạn muốn nghỉ thai
thầu tiêu đề cho khi mà chọn chuột vào
mày vào nó gợi ý một cái gì đó thì nó sẽ
có thêm một vài thuộc tính và xay thô
như thế này dụng là
Ừ chắc chắn đấy ạ
đấy các bạn chỉ vào thì nó sẽ hiển thị
ra như này đâu mà nó sẽ chị Thái Thù
ở
ngoài cái kiểu như này ra các bạn muốn
bấm ở đây nó lại mở ra một cái tab mới
thì các bạn sẽ có khái niệm là ờ
e3z
blank ngay khi nó sẽ bấm vào nó sẽ mở
hẳn ra tát mới phát rét với viết tắt từ
não mình không nhớ lắm mới nhớ hát này
mình nhớ không lầm hát thì nó sẽ Hybrid
em à hay hyperlink hyperlink hyperlink
grad này chắc ạ sẽ điều hướng cái gì lắm
Anh ta ghét Đúng rồi mà Tao ghét rồi ta
ghét gì đấy thì nó sẽ mở mở và like chị
thì nó sẽ là mở ra một tát mới mình nhớ
là hình như là còn cả những cái Mở ra cả
cửa sổ mới cơ Nếu mà cái này cái phổ
biến nhất nên mình chỉ dạy các bạn này
thôi sẽ có rất nhiều cái là mình sẽ chỉ
dạy ở mức độ tương đối các bạn sẽ có thể
thắc mắc là cái này còn có nhiều ngày
nữa mà nhưng mà về các bạn thì HP pro
rất rộng đấy thế nên là mình sẽ
chia sẻ bạn nếu mà các bạn thực sự là
muốn biết đầy đủ tất cả bộ thẻ HTML
không cần lắm nhưng là ra sự các bạn
muốn biết thì các bạn có thể lên những
cái trang giống như w3school để các bạn
biết qua trang này rất là tốt cho cậu nó
có đầy đủ tạo ví dụ cốt các thứ thứ II
ứng
dụng lớn HTML
xe
xôi HM link
hyperlink đúng không Mà nó thế này
thì nó sẽ có những cái kiểu như thế này
nó nó nó bắt buộc phải gạch dưới đúng
không ạ
Ừ đấy thì
anh ở đây có Shell là sẽ là chị defoe là
chính à là cái mở trong trình cái cửa sổ
đấy
Lang là sẽ mở mở ra trong tab mới và 3
lần là sẽ là mở ra hàng mở trong cái
than Friends
anh nói chung ở cái này chắc là các bạn
ít gặp nên là mình sẽ không đề cập tất
cả đây
nhưng đây đây đây mình chia sẻ luôn cho
các bạn một cái trang nữa Mình cũng
thường rất thích tra trên trang này bởi
vì trang này nó có tương đối rất là đầy
đủ thông tin bà cốt cốt nó tưởng Minh
Nhìn cái hình dung luôn Nhưng không ngờ
đọc hết đầy đủ tất cả các mô tả đây đâu
mà mình xem cốt trước đã lập trình viên
mình thứ mấy thế là mình sẽ Xem cốt
trước đã sau đó thì mình mới xe mô tả
mặc định nó sẽ là sale defoe này các bạn
sẽ thấy có tư để phô là mặc định này
sale Tức là nó sẽ trong chính cái Trang
đấy điều hòa ừ ừ
a tiếp theo là mình như mình có nói đó
là nó thậm chí nó thì nhảy đến được cả
một cái ảnh hoặc là nhảy thế hầm trang
web khác mà sửa bây giờ Nếu giả sử và
mình để đến trang google.com nhà cả thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là khi bấm ở đây nó
không ngồi đếm sao google.com mà nó lại
ngồi đền cái file và google.com đúng
không biết cách để các bạn nhảy đến hạn
ra ngoài internet thì các bạn sẽ phải
thêm http suốt như thế này có một vài
Trang nó bảo mật thì phải https đâu à à
anh
bấm này
Ừ đấy thì nó mới nhảy sang hạn cái trang
web khác ngoài
Em Và bạn hoàn toàn thì nghỉ đến mục
file nào đó là sự đây mình sẽ có phải
ảnh đây sẽ có 1 file ảnh ở nó đi
ờ ờ
hình ảnh tôi nhiều lắm mấy ông muốn ảnh
gái xinh thì tượng rõ cái ảnh tao mày
cho mày nhá á
em có ảnh đấy sung off
em đừng báo cáo video này nhé Bây giờ em
vẫn dành cho trẻ con đấy
Nhầm
Thi thoảng mình copy nó bị
trên Mày không nhấn để
đó bơ mình bầm đây là link virus đúng
không bắn 3 này nó sẽ ra cái ảnh đúng
không Ok
Em hãy phải ví dụ như thế mấy ông ấy tôi
ngủ Xin lỗi các bạn nữ Nhưng em à anh
cái xinh mà tôi nghĩa mấy bạn nữ cũng sẽ
thích thôi à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
tiếp theo là có bạn thắc mắc là
tiếp theo là mình sẽ học đến Thay ảnh
của thuộc tính của nó đúng không Đây Giả
sử bây giờ mình sẽ copy thay thế Cái này
làm một cái cái ảnh này không ạ Đây
ảnh của mấy ông này ngắm đi Hãy kiểu
ngay sáng lại thì
mình có thể thêm những thuộc tính cho nó
thuộc thuộc tính của nó sẽ là thay thù
cũng được Hay thổ ví dụ là đây là ảnh
virus trở lại đây Ừ
chị
sẽ có một hôm mình sẽ chỉ nó các bạn về
cái vụ là đúng là máy ảnh Nó có thể tạo
virus thật cái vụ đấy nổ trong cái phim
Huawei
I AM Who are mai đừng có thua May phim
về hacker rất là hay mình yêu mình từng
chỉ các bạn là các bạn nên xem video này
xem cái phim này rồi phim mà cùng hacker
người Nga thì phải
người Nga thì các bạn nổi tiếng rồi nổi
tiếng thấy họ giờ giỏi về hai phục rồi
thì
chặt mình Nó qua một tí về cái đoạn đấy
Đó là
ở đó là người ta gửi cho
bà kia một cái ảnh số một cái ảnh đấy
người ta thật bà đấy chỉ cần click là
cái ảnh thôi bị dính virus nhưng mà thực
tế thì
thì các bạn không hiểu tại sao cái ảnh
Vậy thì chớ virus đúng gọi là bản chất ở
bởi vì cái ảnh đấy nó có slc nhảy đến
một cái đường lâm nguy hiểm Tuy là nó
vẫn ra được cái ảnh Nhưng mà bản chất là
nó kệ rồi C này bản chất nó là gì đây
Bây giờ xử mình cho một kẻ một cái đường
linh như này anh không tồn tại các bạn
sẽ thấy là
các bạn sẽ thấy là cái ảnh nó sẽ bị rạn
lạnh lỗi như này đóng ngoặc
Ừ kệ cái ảnh lỗi này bản chất
ở đầu tiên ở các bạn sẽ phải hiểu tại
sao có ảnh chạy được và ảnh lỗi và bản
chất là nó đều phải gọi được đúng đánh
cái đường dẫn này để lấy cái ảnh về đúng
nhà thì cái thằng hacker nó làm cái trò
đấy Đó là nó sẽ để một cái đinh virus và
khi người dùng loát cái ảnh đấy và tương
đương có việc lal cả trang web virus về
máy của người ta còn việc bấm vào cái
ảnh cô ở đây chỉ để cho sắc xác thực và
điều đấy thôi Bởi vì đôi khi cái mail nó
sẽ không loạt ảnh mà phải bấm Click vào
thì mới class máy ảnh lên Thế nên là quả
đấy nó bị lỗi bị virus hiểu ạ à à
Lý Thái Tổ này sang Thổ này người ta
thay thổ này thì các bạn sẽ thấy là có
bạn vừa hỏi câu rất hay
gì thay đổi thì như mình vừa nãy nói đó
là khi các bạn chỉ và gửi ảnh nó sẽ hiển
thị ra làm cái thai thở bên cạnh nhưng
mà thay thổ này nó khác với kệ i am a
LTE LTE này nó là enter tất cả thay thế
để thay thế cho cái ảnh khi một cái ảnh
nó bị lỗi sự đó đây là ảnh một bạn nhớ
sinh tiếc là
mày ông không tải được
các bạn sẽ thấy là khi mà ảnh đã bị lỗi
ảnh lỗi có thể rất nhiều vấn đề một là
mạnh của ông bị mất này hay là anh ấy bị
xóa rồi đường dẫn thay đổi mới luôn Vân
này đồng ngoại ba là trình duyệt UC nó
không có thể tải được ra cái ảnh ngoan
khi nó sẽ hiển địa hệ erp và Chính vì
cái tên này lại là một cái rất hay nên
tôi xin phép lại phải ngồi trong
Facebook để khoe mi ôm
Nghe ca cổ Ông biết rồi mà có ông mày
trả chưa đâu
ở đây Tôi có đầy ảnh gái xinh cho ông
xem ví dụ giả sử như này đúng không
Không biết anh ở được loại Al chưa thì
bấm vào nhá
ở đây thì các bạn sẽ thấy cái alt của
cái ảnh này nó nó có ghi hẳn đấy
các bạn nó ghi hẳn là như này đúng không
Ảnh chứa hai người
và mọi người đang đứng cái LP của thằng
Facebook sẽ là xịn Nó dùng cái iai để mà
nhận diện được
được cái ảnh nào đang có những vật thể
gì nếu các bạn để ý cái cái vụ altay này
của
của virus và để cho những người không
không xem được người ta bị chúng nó ế
à Dạ không xem được vợ dùng từ như thế
nào nhé
Mình quên xừ mất từ tế nhị ở cho người
ta cứ cho bị mù đúng không người ta bị
mù người ta không xem được người ta sẽ
có thể nghe được cái việc LTE này có dư
thư biết được qua anh đầy Đăng mô tả qua
Bệnh những cái gì ngoài ra là lt này
không phải một tác dụng và như thế mà
tên này để cho những cái công cụ tìm
kiếm như Google treo binh gì đấy coi Tìm
kiếm được Cái trang web đó người khiếm
thị mình tự nhiên mình quên mất cái từ
đấy
thì giữa các trang web đấy Đấy do mấy
ông cha những cái gì gì đó
thì nó ra được cái ảnh rồi ảnh gái xinh
ở lại không ạ ạ
Em đang cần cái này thi thì bạn chất là
trong tiêu đề của cái mấy cái đường dẫn
này đôi khi không có nhắc đến cái từ này
có ảnh nhạy cảm rồi tắt à nhưng trong
art của cái ảnh lại mô tả của có những
cái từ khóa đấy thành ra là ảnh đấy sẽ
được lên Google tìm kiếm đầu hoa
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
đấy đấy qua thì những kẻ thuộc tính của
anh còn gì đấy Nhớ Còn diễm
Và Tôi tin là nãy giờ mấy ông nhớ nhớ
thế Chứng tỏ tốt tôi cố tỉnh dậy mấy cái
vào kiểu
dễ nhớ mà ngon
a tiếp theo là đến thẻ phương tiện là
thẻ đá phương tiện thực ra là tôi nghĩa
từ buổi sau nên để tiếng anh một tí để
cho Công Làm quen với từ tiếng Anh chúng
tôi Dịch ra cái này đôi khi nó cậu mấy
ông lại khó nhớ
ờ ờ
Ừ
thì à ảnh
ảnh thì cũng là một cái đa phương tiện
đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ có những cái gọi là video
cảnh ạ như này có thể thẻ video thẻ
video này hoặc là thận chứa thẻ
nhớ có thể video quả thẻ mùi 13 14 nữa
thì vậy thôi 3hm đầu à
à À đúng rồi thẻ đấy thể tên audio Đúng
rồi Đúng rồi thì
Ừ mình không ngờ chính xác với cái này
và thực sự thực sự để mà nói
ăn mì cay mì gà này
người ta thực tế bây giờ lại rất dậy ít
dùng mày cái thẻ này Tại sao có gì các
bạn bây giờ mình thử dùng các bạn xem
Bạn thấy gần nhiều chẳng Trang web nào
tôi dùng cái thẻ video luôn để tôi xem
có cái có video là trên máy của tôi
không
ý nghĩa tôi không có đi giao cơ à
Ừ hình như ở tôi không có ký giao này
trên máy tôi mất rồi
ừ ừ
anh như thế à
Ê AK đùa nó tôi tôi có mấy cái video
khóa học
Ờ Ờ
nãy giờ sự tiêu hóa ngoài đi à
à
mình mình cứ thử ví dụ cho các bạn xem
một cái thì các bạn sẽ thấy là gần như
là các bạn chưa Rồi thấy cái cái này
trên trên mạng cho nạ kiểu gì thế
à à
ừ ừ
khi chạy thử nhé đó
Ừ cái này nếu mà không trả thêm một cái
gì đó thì sẽ không có nút để bấm luôn sẽ
phải là có thêm những cái thì nhớ không
lầm phải thêm cái thẻ
lại thêm cái play bồ gì vậy ạ
à À đây thêm control đấy lại thêm cân
châu Á
chỉ
có như thế này à
thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là
Ừ cái này rất ít rất ít Trang mà các bạn
thấy
thấy không có cái kiểu video kiểu như
này
Ừ cái giao diện giao diện giao diện
video như thế này sẽ ít luôn Các bạn
thấy bây giờ gần như là nó sẽ ôm của
YouTube này hoặc cả ôm những cái kiểu có
thể Còn nút tua này đồng ngoại còn nứt
to hoặc là nút bật phụ đề đúng không ạ
thì thì cái trong cái thẻ này nó không
hỗ trợ đầy đủ như thế thành ra nó phải
làm hẳn một cái cái cái đúng rồi cái
ieframe giống như nãy giờ các bạn bảo
chứ không dùng cái thẻ thuần như thế này
nữa nên là mình mới chị em chỉ cho các
bạn quay cho các bạn biết thôi
anh
vẫn gặp à đúng rồi Nó những cái trang
kiểu cũ và nó không quan trọng với cái
video thì may ra có Nhưng mà thường mới
được ít lắm
em có cái có thể đôi khi nó hỗ trợ tải
nhớ có hỗ trợ tài nữa
ừ ừ
ở ngoài ra có cảm thẻ MP4 nhưng mà chắc
là các bạn có gì Các bạn cứ tra nhá Nó
ngọt thì các bạn thắc mắc Thủy sao thêm
ở ngoài ra thì mình buổi họp hôm nay ở
thực ra chỉ cần học thêm mà mỗi một cái
thẻ nữa thể danh sách
đâu ạ
anh Bởi vì sao Sao tự nhiên mày học ít
thế mà Bởi vì chủ yếu là
emp3 dụng tương tự các bạn trai m3
HTML ngọn sẽ ra đấy thì bởi vì ah hôm
sau mình sẽ dạy các bạn rất nhiều kiến
thức mới nó là về thẻ form
Ừ thì mình sẽ để dành cho buổi hôm sau
vậy Còn bây giờ thì gần như là hết hết
những cái thử vụn vặt đầy dậy rồi
thế nhưng bài tập hôm nay sẽ có lại là
một bài tổng hợp toàn bộ toàn bộ những
kiến thức đã học các bạn sẽ phải là mỗi
trang web tí tí tí Mình sẽ thử ra đề các
bạn mà đề lần này sẽ để mở mình sẽ yêu
cầu một trang web vào đây đủ sẽ cả những
cái rẻ mà các bạn đã học và các bạn phải
tự làm một cái trang nào nó
theo đúng theo đúng những cái Minh đã
học thì
Ừ thì thành ra là các bạn sẽ thấy da nó
không dễ gì cả các bạn sẽ mất công Mày
làm bài tập để tổng hợp mà đúng không ạ
à à
ạ
Bây giờ là thẻ xanh sách đúng không thể
danh sách thì các bạn lại thấy rất ít
gặp các bạn nghĩ là các bạn sẽ rất ít
gặp bây giờ mình thi thử cho các bạn oll
là lần đầu tiên là mình sẽ chỉ các bạn
với oll trước Noel là cái tắt của Osiris
và thẻ danh sách được sắp xếp sửa đây
mình sẽ có lại xem phim này à
khi sự đề sở thích đi họ
cơ sở thích
xem phim này nghe nhạc này
Hãy giả sử như này nhé
ở đó như thế này cứu mạng sẽ thấy đấy
thẻ danh sách theo kiểu là nó sẽ sắp xếp
nó sẽ tự động tăng tăng dần bọn họ Noel
Noel là odourless nó sẽ tự động sắp xếp
tăng dần
ạ trà sự là à
nhà mình có thể thêm những cái chai cho
nó được sử là mình thêm thai là kiểu y
này lại kiểu la mã chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
biến nó sẽ hiểu thành kiểu đếm theo is a
mã đúng không có thể y thường người ta
nó vững Việt thường hoặc là A như thế
này chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ như thế này a
như thế này chị sẽ nhìn này đủ ngoan nó
thì chỉ có những cái thai kiểu như thế
nhẹ các bạn là thấy à mình khá là ít gặp
mấy cái trường hợp như thế này đúng
không
ừ ừ
ở cây cái ô lỗi gì thuốc là các bạn lại
gặp rất nhiều
anh đố bạn ở biết oli dùng nhiều nhất và
các bạn thường hay gặp nhiều nhất Nó ở
đâu
các bạn thử
thử chỉ thử nói cho mình một mày ví dụ
đâu mà xem mà các bạn biết qua về Oh ly
chưa
all2 danh sách nội dung này
à à
ừ ừ
Mở menu đồ ngon có bạn nói cũng khá đúng
Nói menu đúng không
A gọi điện mình cho các bạn xem qua luôn
Ừ
đúng các bạn đang đang trả lời được thì
chứng tỏ là các bạn học trước rồi thì họ
trước làm tốt đấy thì nó chính là cái
Menu này Đồng hoặc các bạn sẽ để người
ta sẽ chụp ở lại đi đương nhiên là họ sẽ
sắp nó sẽ biến thành hàng ngang nhưng mà
một vài trang nó biến thành luôn hàng
hàng dọc kiểu kiểu như thế này ngon đấy
và nó eol lấy và các bạn thấy nó mất đi
cái số rồi đúng không vì sao với vì hoàn
toàn có thể cho thay bằng năm như thế
này nữa sẽ mất hoàn toàn số đi này
anh nhìn này
Anh năn nỉ
a a 25 mẹ khí như là mình nhớ không lầm
màn hình như phải dùng Xét để làm chữ
ghi như này được không được
ok Nói chung vào cái này vì sau về CS
thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn về làm menu sau
Tiếp theo là
em
có một khái niệm nữa vừa nãy mình nhắn
mạng về cái vụ là Noel là thẻ danh sách
ô ồ thẻ thể danh sách có sắp xếp còn
không sắp xếp thì các bạn chị thay nó nó
ul là ăn order không sắp xếp thì bạn sẽ
thấy em nó sẽ biến Hàng kiểu đó là dấu
chấm như thế này nếu thêm thay cho nó ví
dụ làm mấy cái rồi Square đấy à
Đó
là hình vuông Số 1 Circle rồi mình trí
nhớ và anh cơ bản này thôi chị đấy
Ừ
đấy thì nó sẽ ra kiểu như này nhưng mà
các bạn thấy được cái ngoài đời mình gặp
cũng rất ít trường hợp này đúng là cái
này áp dụng vào Mày ngu như ngoài ra thì
không phải mỗi menu bình thường các bạn
vừa bảo đâu nó bao gồm cả đúng như là
mình nhớ không là mày Như thằng Facebook
nó còn áp dụng cho cả phần là thông báo
này chả mạ hiển thị thông báo này như
cũng là lỗi gì vậy xem thương nhé
em nhớ không lầm hài nó từng áp dụng cho
cả lời cái thử
300 cái giao diện mới này mình được thì
nó đổi hết hành lý rồi nhưng mà mình nhớ
rồi đấy là nó dụng cho cả lời các từ từ
khóa học này sẽ có nói chung là có học
hlcs và ra Speed nhá Cha mình sẽ về gì
rõ lại phần mô tả khẩu khóa học vậy ạ
Ừ đúng rồi cứ rạng danh sách áp dụng
được thì ra là nếu các bạn không biết là
hồi trước rồi Mình nhớ có vài trang nó
áp dụng cho cả ví dụ tin nhắn kiểu như
thế này các bạn đã nhắn tin đúng không
đang như thế này nhưng đó là bản chất nó
danh sách mà không hoàn toàn thể dùng
oliu để đây được vẫn ổn và nó tự động
kiểu xuống dòng các thứ mình sẽ là chỗ
mình thấy khá ổn
ờ
ờ tiếp theo là
em về cơ bản thì các bạn thấy áp dụng
như thế này học tương đối dễ mà nó không
đây gần như toàn bộ kiến thức rồi
ạ sau đó thì bây giờ mới đến cái bài tập
được không ạ bài tập thì mình sẽ ra đề
này à
à à
Tôi thiết kế một website
em có đầy đủ
em
có đầy đủ mà
Các Thẻ đã học
chị sẽ lại
có thẻ
được tiền là hệ tiêu đề không ạ
H1 đến H6 thêm một cho lại
thẻ p.bồ
à à
Anh mơ thấy bà ngoại thì bồ
hệ danh sách
dụ là
ul ly đúng
hẹn Liên kết nó thì ah
à à
vì công việc mà tự nhiên có thể ảnh này
nó ngon cái ảnh đi mother Ê bà
khi con gì nào nhỉ
ở đây
1 để màu đúng không Nhưng mình sẽ thử ví
dụ ví dụ cho các bạn mình sẽ vẽ bằng
Pain đi hơi xấu 1 tí nhưng mình rất
thích vẽ bằng bên đó chưa tưởng
ờ ờ đây
em thật sự đây là có trang web các bạn
anh đúng không
em nộp ở trên Liberty cái trang tich Tac
cái bồ mà mình để cho mô tả ấy thì các
bạn nó nó chụp chụp lại xong rồi tự mình
chấm điểm
ẩm thực gà các bạn không nên được đánh
giá bởi đỉa Bởi vì
tôi mà lỡ để cho mà điểm chín rồi tự
nhiên có ông khác đang đẹp hơn thì tôi
lại địa điểm mười thôi rất khó chịu vụ
đây người thật sự thì các bạn không lên
được không nên được 10 sớm được mưa sớm
tự kia đó các bạn nên chín nó có số dư
là món nào để các bạn vừa điểm cao nó
điểm giỏi mà các bạn sẽ không bao tử kia
à
cho nên thực ra tôi không thích cho chấm
điểm lắm
37 bây giờ thì nhà mình hết trơn rồi nên
mình sẽ nói to hơn tí nên là mình sẽ
không chấm điểm như mình sẽ có nhận xét
dổi cho bạn đã các bạn nên chị à Tí mình
cũng chia sẻ các bạn về đăng Cốt anh có
chuyện kết hát nữa để mà các bạn phải
chia sẻ cho mình cả đường link code để
mình xem qua các bạn cốt như thế nào nữa
điều mà
Ừ
đúng rồi dùng HTML Thôi nhá ông là một
dùng CS ông nào mà chỗ chơi bút chat có
thử thử tôi gạch bài kiểu đấy không phải
là kiến thức tôi dậy
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Vì thế nên là mấy cũng đừng nghĩ việc ăn
trước là đấy đúng không Thì có hai kiểu
còn một trang web thường là các bạn sẽ
có một cái ảnh Đây là một cái ảnh này
cho bạn ảnh lại chọn đúng không các ảnh
bìa đợi sau đó gì một cái tiêu đề ở đây
đây là tiêu đề này trong một bài báo gì
đó lên này nó ngoác xong rồi dưới ấy là
một cái kiểu những danh danh sách danh
sách kiểu đường Linh có thể bấm được để
mà liên hệ ngon thì kiểu như thế thì các
bạn hoàn toàn làm được một cái trang
kiểu như thế này mà được được đóng hoặc
các bạn sẽ chia bố cục bằng Thể Thay bồ
này nó ngoan có 3 có 3 hàng này xong cái
ảnh ở trên này số giữa này Nội dung vào
cuối này là thấy danh sách có y có thử
không ạ Ừ anh em có lỡ ul xong rồi thẻ
có dư đây đúng không và các bạn có thể
hoàn toàn tạo tăng lên Tỷ lệ mình được
khen kiểu thế không những tôi không chấm
điểm đó thì bằng cách là mấy ông phải
chơi những cái kiểu giảm như à
khi tôi có ý một tí nhé
riêng cái thẻ nữa ạ Thế đấy chồng ạ
anh nói chung mà các bạn phải càng nhiều
thuộc tính của mấy cái này càng tốt
thuộc tính Asia Park ở các bạn được học
rồi đúng không và cũng như là thể này
Thực ra có nhiều nhiều cái cách để mà
bấm vào thì sẽ là gọi ông đeo bấm nào để
gọi E Em bấm
vào sẽ gọi được Chẳng ạ Nếu nếu là số
điện thoại nhé hoặc gửi mail Nếu là
email nhá
tư vấn Văn
mình đang gọi ỉa các bạn là có thể làm
những cái kiểu như thế được thì các bạn
hoàn toàn thế ngồi cha cha cái đấy ra là
nó cũng dễ thôi mình từng cho sinh viên
mình sẽ thử và các bạn bên đều làm được
gì
ừ ừ
thế này thì mình mình nghĩ mà hoàn toàn
một là cách là như thế này hay là các
bạn hoàn toàn hệ không thích bố cục kiểu
như thế thì các bạn hãy chia Nó là một
cục kiểu như thế này cũng được đúng
không thường nhiều trang web kiểu như
thế này hoặc hoặc là
ảnh ảnh nền ở đây xong rồi tiêu đề lại
được không sao và vân vân
à à
ở trong HTML mà nhớ ở không có khái niệm
protein phải công ty tôi ở cũng một
thuộc tính nhưng mà nó sẽ chỉ bưu thôi
puti nó theo dạng mà thuộc tính nhưng mà
thuộc tính kiểu
kiểu nó kiểu gì thích không biết dịch
như thế nào đấy Công nhận là nhiều lúc
mình gặp nó nghỉ rồi đấy mình rất khó là
một dịch nó nhưng mà mình hiểu được ra
là ý nghĩa của nó ý
chợ tết bé bài tập của mấy ông điều hòa
chức buổi hôm nay thì ra cũng hết chịu
thước rồi đấy mấy ông thích thì mình
không bị thoát còn bây giờ tôi sẽ Nó
những cái thứ Ngoài Luồng Giống nhờ thức
dậy mấy ông về việc
các bạn kiểu gì Các bạn cũng có thể đăng
ký được một tài khoản ghi thấp rồi Như
hôm trước mình nói là các bạn hoàn toàn
thì nên để mà
Ừ thế được nhưng phải có xe rồi chứ
không
thì
các bạn hoàn toàn thể tạo lưu một cái
Zippo trên này đúng không dụng với mình
sẽ thử ví dụ cho các bạn luôn đấy chị sẽ
là pass của đây chẳng hạn public này ông
ngoại để ý kiện như này
cho Xiaomi tại một cái Zippo rồi mình sẽ
tạo cốt ở trên này gà thực ra là có thể
các bạn có thể chơi kiểu như này các bạn
copy cái này nhé sau đó đi tải về một
cái là giống như mình đang dùng nó là
cái nghĩ hát đến tốp đây vì top top này
các bạn hoàn toàn hệ hát này siro này
ở tại show copy đường dẫn ở đây này vào
cái thư mục của cộng xong rồi Các bạn
chọn đến cái thư mục
em thường nó mặc định tạo ra thư mục thì
các bạn cứ để nó tạo là một thư mục ở
trên của bạn chẳng hạn như thế này đổi
tên nó không nên thừa ra không nên biết
hoàng nha nhưng viết thường thôi
Đúng rồi Các bạn nên làm quen bằng lệnh
cũng được Mình đang chỉ có bạn cho bạn
dễ hiểu nhanh thì nó sẽ ra kiểu như này
ạ sau đó thì các bạn sẽ chèn hết file
vào trong trong người thêm một ngày thôi
là sự bây giờ mình sẽ có
ở một vài cái file đúng
à à
tham gia sự mình sẽ copy về chị sẽ lưu
vào file này vào trong cái thì mua Kia
chẳng ạ
chủ đề bài này
vì thế bạn sẽ thấy à trong cái trong cái
này nó sẽ hiển thị ra được những cái
thay đổi ở trong thư mục này các bạn
hoàn toàn ghi chú thích khi mà đẩy một
cái file đó lên như thế này Hoặc là các
bạn nó nó tự động điền hộ các bạn cũng
được nếu các bạn không thích ghi chú hết
gì cả nhưng mình khuyên là các bạn về
sau Dân công nghệ thì các bạn mỗi lần 7
cốt đêm là các bạn ghi chú thích gì đó
à Xong rồi bây là mình sẽ con nít đẩy
lên này xong rồi mình đẩy thẳng lên như
thế này Thế là xong nó tự nhiên nó sẽ
yêu cầu thêm các bạn nữa về vụ là bạn
Nhập thì các bạn chỉ đăng nhập vào thôi
là xong đấy khi ba đầy cốt lên đi xong
được Cái trang kiểu như này rồi là sự
bây giờ mình sẽ có file đi
em inbox code
chị đói một bài rồi
I read file sửa demo chấm Alo
Hello cho nào ạ
Ừ cái gì này
có ai là sự có pha như này rồi nhé các
bạn đang xuất tinh này nó Tết này
à Xong rồi à
a
vicious xe
Anh nói như thế này các bạn vào được cái
trang này và các bạn gõ đi mô thôi
thì nó sẽ đợi một tí
âm nhạc Bạn đợi đi cho iPad Piece One
hỏi xem à à
a nhớ phải đợi một tí để mà hiển thị ra
được đấy các bạn sẽ thấy được xa trang
web để ngoan là sự ra cốc được các bạn
thì các bạn chỉ cần nói Vào setting
vinapay sao nó có sẵn hướng dẫn này đều
ngoan
ừ ừ
anh không không không cần phinx chấm tt
làm gì cả các bạn hoàn toàn để gõ chấm
đầy đủ HTML ở đây nha thằng cái tháp này
tự động hiểu rồi thế xong
ở chỗ nào bán chỗ nào thì 99 cái Linh mô
tả các trang tiết cái bồ đấy các bạn
hoàn toàn là là là hai cái
cái link phim phần mô tả đúng không các
bạn vào đấy các bạn bình luận cho mình
cái cày cái trang web của các bạn để
mình vào
số tiền mình xem cốt nữa ngon
anh không một cái Trang đi pô này thì
các bạn hoàn toàn thể tạo rất nhiều file
mà không ạ Các bạn thấy em mình phải gõ
hẳn demo chấm HTML để mà ra rồi Cái
trang web đấy các bạn hoàn toàn để tạo
file file tên là bội 1723 chẳng hạn đóng
ngoặc đấy thì nó hợp lý hơn mình Anh chỉ
ví dụ thấy thằng này thôi để mà các bạn
về son Vào cái đường link rồi các bạn
chỉ cần buổi một chị sẽ ra bài thứ nhất
12 ra bài thứ hai nó không tí hơn đúng
không ạ
anh không không phải đi có đâu trên chỉ
mô tả của cái video các bạn đang xem có
cái
ở trên YouTube này này
nghe có phần mô tả có phần đường Linh
rồi đấy
So sánh Đấy vừa nói qua bây giờ rồi các
bạn mình chưa nói cụ thể về các bạn cách
sử dụng ít lắm Bởi vì thực sự thì mình
nghĩ là chưa đến lúc mà các bạn hiểu
được cái đấy lắm
để khi mình dạy sang bên web mình còn
đang nghĩ mình đang nghĩ vì không biết
được làm như thế nào nhưng mà mình đang
nghĩ việc là khi mà mình dậy các bạn về
làm web thì ra hồi ở công ở trường mình
được học là kiểu gì cũng sẽ z22 bạn bắt
buộc phải bạn không nên đông quá bạn
cũng không nên là một mình bởi sao rồi
nên làm quen dần việc cả làm việc theo
nhóm
Vì thế nên là ở trường mình hồi đấy toàn
là hai bạn cùng một nhóm để làm một cái
đầu ám là làm được trang web Vì như mình
đã nói có thể chọn web bán hàng hoặc
cùng trong bếp tin tức
mình nghĩ đấy là một cái khá hay không
biết là các bạn có thích kiểu làm việc
theo nhóm nhưng mà mỗi tội là nhóm chỗ
này lại đang nhóm Online kiểu như thế
chắc là vài bạn thì không gặp được nhau
nhưng mà mình nghĩ là
Em nghĩ thế thì sẽ kiểu cho các bạn làm
quen với việc làm cho nhóm
sẽ sẽ có bạn theo kiểu là có bạn vào bạn
biết sự hết rồi
nhờ có hai bạn sẽ yếu có thể cùng một
nhóm vân vân vân Nhưng mà sẽ làm làm thế
để làm quen với việc là mình
gọi như nàng mình quen việc làm thiện
theo theo tập thể rồi vì thực sự đi làm
nó khi các bạn cũng sẽ như thế mà cái
mình ra cân nhắc
anh Bởi vì thực sự thì à
em làm cái đấy xong còn liên quan việc
bảo vệ cơ Tôi không biết rồi Tôi thường
này cho các bạn làm xong đùa đấy xong
tầm 23 tháng ngồi làm sau đó thì sẽ có
bảo vệ trước hội đồng
Ừ tôi không biết được Hồi đấy tôi từng
cho sinh viên mình bảo vệ suốt rồi
anh cũng tầm hơn hình chụp lớp mỗi thì
cũng hơn trăm bạn rồi nhưng mà không có
bảo vệ cùng một lúc như thế
em thấy chúng mình đang cất nhắc mày
thấy đấy thôi
Ừ nhưng mà cái đấy nghe có vẻ hay mà
muốn được thực sự thì các bạn sẽ cảm
thấy nó rất là ý nghĩa khi các bạn được
bảo vệ Làm bực một sản phẩm rất là ổn
rồi bảo vệ trước các thầy để mà có thầy
chấm sẽ mình đã làm được như thế nào để
loa
Em hãy mình cảm thấy đấy nó có gì đó tạo
cho các bạn rất nhiều động lực cũng như
là áp lực có áp lực rất lớn có các thầy
thuốc liên tục nhưng mà kiểu
Ừ đúng kiểu sau hai cái đồ nhá đầy sinh
viên của mình khác biệt hẳn nên là mình
cảm thấy cái đấy rất là Úc
Ừ chắc là ổn Đấy
vì mình không biết được à Có nên làm thế
với các bạn không nhưng mà bảo vệ thế
xong các bạn xả sản Tam thẳng thích cụ
ở quy mô nó không ăn lớn đâu nhưng mà nó
cũng phải là gần làm xong được một trang
web gỡ một trang web
Ừ tao ốm mà
Ừ đúng rồi thực ra mình đang nghĩ việc
là ở đây rất khó mà Có bạn nào đang đang
học được bỏ dở nửa chừng mà các bạn học
ở đây nó nó kiểu dạng là các bạn đã tinh
thần tự học đã cao ấy các bạn không chị
F1 vừa học mà nên là tinh thần tự học
các bạn cao thì là mình nghĩ là hoàn
toàn phù hợp làm được cái vụ đấy bởi vì
hồi mà mình dạy sinh viên mình người
đúng là sinh viên nhiều sinh viên nạn
người ta bỏ vì họ thực sự không đam mê
Cái này này nhưng mà ở đây thì chắc là
các bạn bỏ để các bạn bỏ ngay từ đầu các
bạn không phải đến lúc đấy mới bỏ
thế hả bạn đang nói về cái bài tập thì
bài tập cũng có CF is a sweet Nếu bài
tập này và nếu cấp bạn đang hỏi về cái
việc cái đồ bàn đấy đồ án đấy thì sẽ làm
trang web cơ bản là hplc ra Swift là mai
que le với pp đầy đủ Có thấy rồi
Việt Nam hạng của trang web kiểu để mà
ra được một cái sang cho
à à
ở nhà được một sản phẩm hoàn thiện
Ê thằng Trung Hòa Bình sẽ đi tất cả đề
tài này sau đó gì à
mục tiêu chí của từng trang web này để
cho các bạn ạ căng biết mình nói đang
rất nghiêm túc đấy các bạn làm xong rồi
Cái đấy cũng là một thứ để mà các bạn
khoe đi phỏng vấn luôn nên là rất là
căng đấy mình sẽ
à à thôi Đấy mình chửi sinh viên mình
nhiều phép không không dám chửi tao bạn
ở đây nhưng ạ xác định là hồi đấy Mình
rất là căng ông nào mà lệch một tí ông
ấy tự ý thay đổi bà ta bay này ông ấy tự
ý làm việc ý riêng mà không hỏi qua
Thuận qua mình đấy mình không cho bảo vệ
luôn mình cho cho bảo vệ năm sau luôn có
gần ngựa chuột đấy anh ạ cậu
cho ra áp lực nhưng mà chính vì như thế
mới hiểu các bạn mới phải quen với cái
áp lực đấy thì mới đi làm được đúng
không
à à
thì các bạn phải quen được đấy Không có
thể tự ý ông tự ý đi thay đổi đang giúp
ai mà không khỏi leader không hỏi kiểu
trưởng nhóm được đúng không không hỏi
thầy không hỏi mày đi chữa có ông hướng
lên Tự ý thay đổi gì gì đó là bị phạt để
điều chắc chắn
cho nên là mình nghĩ cái đấy tự nhiên
mình nhắc đến mẹ cảm thấy kích thích có
chiều mình nằm thấy cậu Cái này nó nó
là thứ khiến cho
sinh viên mình từng thành công và mình
nghĩ à mình áp dụng được với các bạn
anh Đương nhau các bạn chị chỉ làm
online được cho nó có rất nhiều hạn chế
nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà cậu
nó Minh nghĩ bắt buộc phải có những áp
lực gì đó cũng như là các bạn bảo vệ
xong thành công xong thích cực nóng bỏng
à à
ở đây mình cái đấy vừa rồi không hẳn là
chém gió nhé Mình cũng đang nói với cái
định hướng đúng ạ trực tiếp theo là mình
à
cho phép chia sẻ thêm những cái là dụ là
cái trang cote này các bạn thấy mình mở
khá nhiều trong copain này
trang này một trang rất là hay mình từng
biết đó là thưởng này chia sẻ rất nhiều
cái á những cái cậu code HTML ra Swift
và CF
thời trang rất đẹp đợi tí
Vì sao nó cứ hiển thị ra cái cho word
này nhỉ
à à
Ừ thôi nghỉ
tại sao nó có hiển thị nở cho word nhé
Ê Ti Viettel
Nghe bài Đám cưới Vào Hạnh Phúc à
em à cái hồi đấy mình làm mình có pi cốt
mà
à à
Vì
vậy các bạn thấy là khi bấm vào xe mà
lại có rất nhiều cái đẹp
ờ ờ Cậu bấm vào xem chi tiết nó sẽ có
chia sẻ cho các bạn cả HTML và CSS các
bạn hãy copy về chạy được luôn các bạn
sẽ thấy có rất nhiều cái ở trên cái
trang coupon này mình sẽ để mua cho các
bạn vài cái
dụ là đây mình có lưu rất nhiều đồ ngoan
ý
cho ví dụ điển hình cái này cái này hình
như chia sẻ qua không biết là có phải
trong nhóm mình nhé Không nhưng mà đây
bạn ơi việc mà lại các bạn sẽ thấy giờ
ổn không quá Cái này là ảnh không những
ảnh nó còn có và có thể video đấy nhá
Ừ ông nào mang về rồi ông chị còn thay
đường dẫn là cái ảnh bạn gái ông nữa ông
thì đây cậu yêu em hay chúc mừng sinh
nhật này Thế còn nhớ xong có cái khỏe
mạnh khỏe dồi Đông ạ Các bạn hãy bấm vào
đây để xem à rượu phiên bản Xem Full
page xem
anh nghe chọn đẹp không ạ
Ừ chị mã xỉ mạnh Đúng rồi đấy tôi cũng
bắt chước rồi làm
em có rất nhiều cái hay nữa mình mới xem
qua đây lại thêm có rất nhiều cái nữa
các
bạn có rất nhiều giao diện da đẹp các
bạn chỉ việc off cột b là chạy thành ra
cầu mình thấy trang trang kute này cậu
Ừ thứ nhất là mình không mình bản thân
mình không làm được tất cả lúc 12 vì
mình không chưa đều diện mà mình không
thể dạy các bạn được những cái điều này
được nhưng mình sẽ dạy các bạn để các
bạn có thể họ nhà mình có anh dùng từ
sinh viên là mình thường ai gọi đi ăn
cắp cốt rồi hết mình sẽ thời gian diện
là đẹp thì mình hoàn toàn thể biết copy
Cốt về chính sữa đái kẹp như thế Cái đấy
mình sẽ đủ mình sẽ học đủ kiến thức để
mình làm được những cái điều đấy mình
hoàn toàn thể lấy copy người giao diện
nó nó về và sửa theo ý mình
đi đường nhờ tôi không khuyên hẳn mấy
ông mà cứ đi ăn cắp của theo diện người
ta về nó liên quan bạn bản quyền nữa
Nhưng nhưng trên mấy cái trang này nó
trên sẽ miễn phí này nên hoàn toàn hoàn
toàn là mấy ông có thể đến đây thì đem
về cho chính cái đồ ăn Sắp tới có thể
mình bảo đây không ạ mấy cái trang này
đẹp lắm
ô tô lửa bao nhiêu
em có và giao diện từ đăng nhập này xong
lỗi giao diện các thứ thứ
cố gắng mạnh mẽ thời trang coupons
à à
10 cái bài toán ở đây đó là các bạn
Ừ mình đang hướng các bạn là về bát em
nhiều hơn với fan file các bạn phải học
để mà chuyên được nghe và các bạn phải
có mắt thẩm mỹ nữa thành ra là các bạn
rất khó làm được như này Đây là mình
mình không không khuyến khích các bạn về
việc các bạn phải giỏi về bên phe này để
làm được như này nhưng hoàn toàn và
người tạm chia sẻ rồi mà chia sẻ một cái
kiểu cho các bạn để các bạn thể đem về
Mà đúng thì các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ lấy mà dùng thôi nhưng mà mình
đang dạy các bạn cũng có kiến thức để
các bạn có thể sửa nó chẳng phải ôm Minh
Uyên về ông không biết sửa thì giờ nóng
mặc
thì thế nên là các bạn không phải lo
việc à là cái này gọi đi ăn cắp về hay
là kiểu mình sẽ copy paste hay gì đó mà
cái này đã được
áo kiểu dạng là
mình sẽ tham khảo dùng từ tham khảo
chúng nó hơi quán hơi nói giảm nói tránh
quá cái chỗ mình lấy về nhưng mà cái
quan trọng khi mà một cái trang web chị
không phải là mỗi giao diện các bạn phải
hình dung việc là khi mà các bạn học
sang công nghệ thông tin rồi Chỉ cần một
trang web chị nó không phải bài toán về
diện nó diện nó chẳng làm cái gì cả cũng
trọng bảo vệ cái bác em của nó đúng
không thế thế nên là mình dạy các bạn là
chuyên sâu về bác em hơn cái giao diện
thì đúng là ông nào chuyên hẳn giao diện
để làm được cái đẹp ngay lương cao đấy
nhưng mà phải phải có mắt thẩm mỹ rồi có
mực biết thì phô shop có thử thứ nhiều
cái cơ
em còn mấy ông ở đây thì mày ông chưa
chắc ạ Đã có hạn năng khiếu phải cái vụ
đấy và tôi hướng đến mẹ các bạn đã đang
hướng về tư duy để mà các bạn làm được
một cái gì đó thì tư duy Nói chung là ờ
khi cài sau kế khóa học quét cơ bản này
mình khẳng định là ai cũng học được cái
khói cơ bản cơ bản này nhưng mình đã đề
cập ở cái vụ mô tả mô tả của cái khóa
này là hai cũng học được cái khóa wep cơ
bản này không nên mức độ khó các bạn
không cần phải theo ngành Công nghệ
thông tin để mà các bạn học cái khóa này
anh Bởi vì toàn bộ những cái mình sẽ dạy
đúng rồi nó là cơ bản Nó kiểu nó không
Không gì nặng nề cả các bạn học khoa các
bạn hoàn toàn trật tự làm cái trang web
Ừ đúng là tốn mất 23 tháng thật nhiều
kiểu gì có bạn sẽ làm cái trang web cho
xin các bạn và các bạn sẽ nhìn
anh nhìn mọi cái đồ công nghệ các bạn
đang dùng hàng ngày bằng một con mắt
khác
Ừ đấy Giống như hôm trước tôi chia sẻ
mấy ông ấy việc Tải ảnh đấy các bạn rõ
là các bạn gặp dưới suốt nhưng mà các
bạn đâu Nhận ra các bạn tải được cái ảnh
hay video từ sau khi dễ yên thế đúng
không ạ gì đấy Tôi sẽ dậy dần dần mấy
ông để mấy ông hiểu được là trình nõ
cũng không nhiều quá quá ghê gớm nhưng
mà Đúng là khóa sau khi mà nhảy sang lập
trình web chuyên sâu thì các bạn
Khi nào thực sự mà muốn theo ngành Công
nghệ thông tin các bạn học xong khóa cơ
bản các bạn cảm thấy đo áp lực quá các
bạn thấy nó cũng phải khó A và 05 mê nó
Các bạn hãy dừng lại có bạn không theo
cái khóa trên trâu nữa không ạ
A và Cái quan trọng là tất cả đều miễn
phí miễn phí ở đây là miễn phí cho tôi
thôi nhưng mà không nên miễn phí a các
bạn các bạn vẫn sẽ phải tốn thời gian
cho nó rất nhiều thứ nó đồng loạt
anh không không phải về mỗi Tiền đâu
đúng không tiền đưa nó chả là cái gì đấy
cả à
Vì thế nên là các bạn phải cân nhắc
nhưng mà tới cho khóa chim sâu con khóa
cơ bản này mình nghĩ là
Ừ nó cũng gần như vừa học vừa thư giãn
một tí bởi vì nó không mặt khó quá đi
ừ ừ
Ừ mình nguy nói qua với mình cái đấy
tiếp theo làm mình mình ghi ở đây đó là
chữ ký email
anh ở đây à Đây là logo công ty mình xóa
hết tên công ty rồi để có 1 logo thôi
Thực sự đó là
mình đang thấy có rất nhiều bạn chưa
biết về cái vụ làm chữ ký Email bởi vì
là kẹo Các bạn kiểu
ờ ờ không chuyên nghiệp lắm kể người
khóc tỉ mỉ lắm Mình nghĩ đấy hoa cà chị
ăn Dạ là một con người đơn giản đấy như
thế được sự thì nếu mà ông muốn thể hiện
mình trong chuyên nghiệp của họ muốn
kiểu dạng là
Ở trong chị so với cả vụ gửi mail các
bạn cũng phải tinh tế đúng thì các bạn
Cha xin chào này nó nhắn email sau cái
template này xảy ra rất nhiều trang để
mà Tạo email miễn phí và tạo chữ ký
email miễn phí rồi về mở trang điện hình
mình đang dùng cái template này sẽ ra
kiểu như này điều hòa
Em hãy trộn ca sĩ nữa mà đông
Ở đây các bạn hãy copy xong rồi các bạn
dán trong cái phần cài đặt của mail các
bạn
ở đây nó có kiểu điền thông tin bình
thường bình thường thôi Bây giờ có bạn
copy vào xong rồi
Chú Gián phần cài đặt để mỗi lần các bạn
gửi mail kèm theo chữ ký cho nó ngầu
đúng không Trông kiểu dạng là được mình
chuyên nghiệp được ngon
tại mình và toàn bộ Cái này Tại sao mình
Nó qua cái này thì toàn bộ Cái này toàn
là HTML trên thứ mà các bạn đã học rồi
đúng không ạ Đây thẻ này đúng không bấm
đây A này Ừ vậy thì ảnh ngon a
thẻ hắn một tiêu đề cho tư song
ừ ừ
ở mỗi ông nên có một cái gì đó cao uống
cái dấu ấn kiểu gì đó
à
Còn cái gì thì chia sẻ Các bạn nha Mình
định bảo chia sẻ cả về cái tiện ích mà
mình thường anh dùng vào đây nữa Nhưng
mà thực ra còn bốn phụ để mà kết thúc
buổi học hôm nay mình chia sẻ nhanh nhé
các bạn nốt cái Trang mà mình đang dùng
để mà làm ảnh đại diện đi nếu mà ngoài
chưa biết
nay với poster ạ
à à
những kẻ xanh sân này cho ra để buổi sau
vậy nhé
Ừ thế bạn nào chưa biết thì ảnh mình sẽ
tạo ra bởi Cốt
anh cái ảnh đại diện mình đang để nó là
ảnh của mình xong rồi mình đang lên
trang này nó biến thành cốt cái này
trông hai tôi sổ chia sẻ dòng máy ông
đồng loạt mình không được tiền à
ở những cái kiểu này trông rất hay và
các bạn hỏi nói thế copy rồi đoạn không
phải mỗi cốc mà các bạn copy lời bài hát
trong ai được
Thật sự tôi ví dụ đây trong mấy ông nhé
bài hát mãi không
à à
cho anh nhé nó mặc định nhìn này rồi nếu
hoàn toàn là mấy ông có thể
anh có thể cậu copy uống thứ gì đó thôi
đấy tôi nghe Mạnh Tuấn copy sư cái thư
viện Giao về cho nó nhậu cái gì này
em
lấy từ chuyên gia này nhanh à
à à
cho
anh tiền nhà copy về
xe xôi dám lấy
em có đi
Ở đây nắng quá
copy luôn rồi nhờ
xe máy tông đơ
Xin chào bạn này nó dài quá
bây giờ các bạn chuyển copy phần má có
pin phần đoạn này sau đó dán vào cũng
được
sau đó chị Play nó sẽ ra đoạn cốt này
kiểu kiểu như thế
a Blind nó sẽ ra đón Cốt
Em hãy trong nhà sự thực là người ta
không nhìn thấy cốt của ông đâu nhưng mà
kiểu khi người ta rung lên thì không
thấy kiểu áo dân cũng mệt đấy
hình ảnh tạo bởi cốt trong lâu vãi
chưởng người ta là cái gì
ừ ừ
Em hãy thế xong ngủ ngon ông Trịnh Trịnh
thêm gì nữa số ông bán tải về phía sóng
Ừ thế còn giờ ông có thứ cậu dạng mà
kiểu thể hiện mình là dân cũng nghệ rồi
đi lại người được
à à khi tôi chia sẻ bí quyết của tôi
về đấy về cả ảnh đại diện đấy
Ừ nó Bé con vừa kịp thời gian đúng không
nhờ đăng ký và ra lỗi
ở ngoài chợ tạm nghỉ tại đây nhé Còn hôm
sau tôi sẽ chia sẻ mấy ông về toàn bộ
những cái accession với đang dùng và tôi
từng chia sẻ rồi nhưng mà để
trước tôi dùng còn bây giờ tôi dùng ít
hơn và không thêm một ngày mới chia sẻ
sau A
Anh ấy thì các bạn thấy là học Thực ra
là hôm nay khá ít nhưng mà
Ừ nó làm cái gì đó thư giãn cho mấy ông
ở trong một buổi tối đúng không không
không nên học gì đó nặng nề quá nhưng
buổi sau thì mình khẳng định là buổi sau
sẽ sáng là đã nhấn với toàn phá nhiều
cái mới các bạn đã quá muộn lo quá trước
để các bạn đọc về form HTML của mình nhé
Đừng để các bạn đi qua trước
ở bài hôm nay thì tím mình sẽ đăng bài
lên
khi nào mình hết rồi nhỉ À
em buổi sau học form xong chắc là cũng
là hết kiến thức về bên HTML sau đó thì
mình sẽ nhận sáng sẽ và bài toán Đấy là
tùy kiến thức mình mỗi buổi chia sẻ Thực
ra nó cũng ít nhưng mà không có ôn lại
thành ra các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ phải tự là bài nhiều để nhớ đúng
không ạ anh ạ
anh không form HTML không ghét ta thì cả
chỉ đơn giản là nó là những cái thẻ nằm
trong phòng thôi
hơn ở chỗ này chào các bạn ạ